[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZISL SLEPOVITCH: Hello.
My name is Zisl
Slepovitch, and I'm
musician in residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies.
This video series is designed
as a companion to our album,
Where Is Our Homeland?
which is the first volume
in the archive's ongoing effort
to present songs and poems
performed by survivors
in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more
about the project
on the archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland--
Songs From
Testimonies Volume One
was recorded in 2019 by the
Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
featuring renowned
singer Sashe Lurje;
Craig Judelman on the
violin; Joshua Camp
on the accordion,
keyboards, and guitar;
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass;
and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly
in terms of style, social
and historical background,
language, and many
other aspects.
But collectively, they create
a multidimensional picture
of Jewish life before
and during World War II.
Liubov K. was born in 1921
in Zvenigorodka, Ukraine.
The four pieces-- two
songs and two poems--
she performed during her 1994
testimony about her experiences
in the labor camps
surrounding her hometown are
unique historical
documents telling
the story of the camp prisoners'
everyday struggle for survival.
The camps themselves, the nearby
villages where the inmates used
to escape to get food,
and Stepan, camp guard
are named in the two
of the four texts.
"In dem kleimen Dorf,
in Smiltschenzi"--
"In the small village
of Smiltschenzi"--
is a fascinating example of
the native Yiddish speakers
to compose a song in
German under the harshest
of conditions.
The result is a mixed
almost, macaronic text,
largely in German with a
few Yiddishisms mixed in.
The song conveys the
suffering of Jewish mothers
who were separated
from their children
and longed for their homes.
The style and form
of the song are
reminiscent of the
Weimar Republic period
cabaret and theater songs,
very much in the spirit
of Kurt Weill.
An indirect clue
that the song may not
have been originally composed
by the labor camp inmates in--
is the widespread use of
popular songs with new texts
during World War II.
LIUBOV K.: In the little
village Smilchyntsi
In the camp the Jews are living
miserably
Hear the women crying
Crying without end
Where is our homeland?
When will we return?
In the stall we live
like pigs
Hungry as dogs are we
A child
without a mother
A mother without child
Where is our homeland?
When will we return?
Jews, o Jews, o how
we suffer
Nothing like it was ever known
The tears we've wept
Could be rivers
The blood we've spilled
Could be an ocean
The tears we've wept
Could be rivers
The blood
we've spilled
Could be an ocean
That's it.
[MUSIC, "IN DEM KLEINEM DORF IN
SMILTSCHENZI"]
SASHE LURJE: In the little village Smilchyntsi
In the camp the Jews are living miserably
Hear the women crying
Crying without end
Where is our homeland?
When will we return?
In the stall we live like pigs
Hungry as dogs are we
A child without a mother
A mother without child
Where is our homeland?
When will we return?
Jews, o Jews, o how we suffer
Nothing like it was ever known
The tears we’ve wept
Could be rivers
The blood we’ve spilled
Could be an ocean
The tears we’ve wept
Could be rivers
The blood we’ve spilled
Could be an ocean
SARAH GARIBOVA: Smiltschenzi
was the second camp
Liubov was taken
to during her time
as a forced laborer on the
Transit Highway IV Project
in German-occupied Ukraine.
She was there from the
early summer of 1942
until December of that year.
As in Nemorozh, the
previous camp, Liubov
and her fellow prisoners
lived in a stable
and slept on straw on the floor.
In these camps,
the constant threat
of punitive executions
and mass shootings
hung over the prisoners.
In their early
days in the camps,
the prisoners did
not fully understand
the brutality of the German
and Ukrainian camp guards.
Little did they know that the
German occupiers had designated
anyone incapable of work as,
quote, "a superfluous mouth"
doomed to execution.
As Liubov recalls, quote, "We
had just arrived here to work,
and we didn't know yet whether
we had the privilege of getting
sick or not.
Four people fell
ill, three women--
two women, one girl--
and a boy.
So they stayed in the barn.
They didn't go to work.
That evening when we
returned from work,
the gendarmerie
turned up unexpectedly
and had us line up
outside along the stable.
They went inside.
The sick people were
lying in their beds.
They pulled them up and shot
them behind the other stable."
The girl who was sick
managed to run away,
but when she reached the
fence stile to escape,
she was met by Silich,
a Ukrainian guard.
As Liubov recalls, quote,
"He grabbed her by the hair
and brought her back.
They shot her," end quote.
What happened next is even
more heart-wrenching, though.
Like many of the young
folks in this labor camp,
the young girl who had been
shot had relatives still alive
in the Zvenigorodka ghetto.
And at the time,
relatives from the ghetto
would periodically
visit the camp
to bring their loved ones food.
This girl's mother was among
those regular visitors.
After the girl was shot,
Liubov and her fellow prisoners
couldn't bring
themselves to tell
the mother what had happened.
So they told her to ask
one of the guards instead.
He simply said, I can't
tell you anything.
The mother persisted.
The prisoners finally told her
that the girl had fallen ill
and that it was forbidden
to enter the camp.
Rather than
deterring the mother,
this prompted her to return
to the camp for the next three
days to bring food
for her daughter.
And this lasted until
the politsai told her
what had actually happened.
The mother lost her mind
and then was also shot.
Such stories played out over
and over again in the camps,
inspiring the words
of the song, quote,
"A child without a mother,
a mother without a child.
The tears we've wept
could be rivers.
The blood we've spilled
could be an ocean."
[MUSIC PLAYING]